hello welcome back to gamespot presents
the mix here at GDC 2015 i'm here with
humor own or am i who [ __ ] knows how
you down my friend how you doing good
morning good to see you welcome to the
wonderful world of san francisco it's
the only place in the world or in North
American isn't covered in snow so how
interesting that you've managed to wear
your your snowblind list situation so I
mean I my identity is one of the
government's closely kept secrets but we
know you're a teenager yes that's all we
got there and you were sick floral
shirts mm-hmm that's great got a great
max payne vibe going i'll yeah at drift
stage this game looks i'm super rad tell
me about it well it's a game it's the
game confirmed it's just like a kind of
like a shout out to kind of the late 80s
Early 90s arcade racers I know the good
the heyday of drifting yes before the
[ __ ] big corporation convo yeah is
not a sim we're very much on our case
arcade side of things that's really
they're all is to it I mean do we want
to jump in sure yeah absolutely this
this stage is yours for the next like 12
minutes or so so do whatever you want
all right want to show me your game you
want to talk about your favorite bands
you wanna you can chew it out about Isis
or something wrong whatever Isis yeah
Isis the band or Isis all shower [ __ ] it
dog all right all right appreciate our
yeah i just realized that's really
[ __ ] them up yeah that's right he
busted their SEO yeah it's like what do
you even do so this is our our time
trial free demo that's out on each i/o
right now it's one level whoa this is
the first time i've ever played this
with vibration arena wasn't aware that
that was a teacher but hey you guys just
adding pre GDC features yeah hey you
know like I'm just a music guy you know
he's just pretty great in this game hey
it's alright it's not bad
yes so we got one level controls we
we've kind of really try to put a focus
on making the game very immediate and
that you can kind of pick it up pretty
quickly I mean there's it's not really
like that complex of a mechanic why did
what do you print is a predominantly
time trials are racing against other
drivers we're going to do we just have a
time trial for now but we're hoping to
do like four player split screen there
will be a career mode level editor so
people can create on tracks yeah that
I'm really excited about at the color
palette if I seen a bunch of screenshots
where it's kind of all I know the cars
look incredible their own like funky
different colors and what is it always
this super-intense all the time yes good
all right it's the only way it's only
maybe you've got your own branding up on
the wall as well I see ya just my wrong
guitar still of course um that actually
wasn't my idea yeah they just needed
billboards yeah add to the rich fiction
of the university or say maybe they
think I'm a pretty cool guy have you
done music from your video games no this
is my process this is my first time
doing easy for a game it's my first time
being on streaming oh really yeah well
we know actually why did you I didn't we
don't see your face yeah well I showed
up today I thought I was just doing an
interview I yeah just stick you on his
couch and you you know just on the email
chain like oh the show free interview at
the farm look like okay see at you whack
like oh go do this interview
and then like go do some other stuff but
it's like oh you're gonna be on TV like
right now Chucky coming to CBS building
tell us about your Kickstarter actually
because you guys have a it was like a
30,000 and did you like almost hit
double that almost double I think we're
at like 57 it's closed now the right of
clothes a month ago or so we were
successfully fun congratulations yes
thank you and what's it like going down
that route if you ever like what's it
like working on a project you think like
[ __ ] man this all this effort might
actually not end up catching people's
attention well I mean there's there's
always of course that constant fear but
this is one of the best projects that
I've ever worked on and that the three
of us are there are two other people on
the project there's chase the programmer
and Charles the art guy but we're all
three pretty much on the same page and
the project's really nice in that we
have the freedom to do our like do our
own thing that's interesting cause the
music yeah he's in charge of the art and
chases in charge of programming and we
all have suggestions for each other but
we're kind of it's like one of the most
liberating projects I've ever been
involved with it's weird having that
sort of autonomy the straight guy run a
couple minutes ago and like it I think
that's like a something you see a lot in
the indie scene where like people
working remotely isn't that different
it's not unusual where's obviously in
like most game development having you
know immediacy between teams is really
important yeah like what's it like for
you working with like yeah like seeing
this thing like come together piece me
and I'm working with somebody who's on
the other side of the world or others
other country well the whole thing is
super eye-opening for me because I've
never would worked on a game before so
I'm like the fish out of water but you
know in music world I you know I've
worked with people like electronically
as well no it hasn't really been that
different than that
but do you think just in terms of like
the game itself you've obviously talked
a lot but the Mo's are involved and are
we looking at sort of one of the easier
levels in it doesn't get into like sort
of i'm a big white bad fan like talking
about nineties racing games does it get
like into a crazy difficult territory or
is it a visibility on the flow to be
honest like we only have about one and
there's another level if it's kind of
like half done but one of the things
that we're working on is getting this
level editor together so that the three
of us can start designing levels and
then also people who I guess have access
to the beta builds and start designing
levels to oh wow we want to make it so
that pretty much like you'll be able to
like like recreate this track in the
level editor it'll be pretty deep you're
going to get the community to sort of
adds to this or overall content that
drift stage will have one said yeah I
think so i think the three of us might
handle like the official tracks yeah you
know who knows like you have the beauty
of doing all this stuff on the internet
and through kickstarter is that like you
can get really great feedback from your
users and change stuff up to let the
game kind of take you where it needs to
go how did you get involved in this to
self to play games yourself much at all
uh yeah i mean kind of I just to be
honest i found i saw a gift of one of
these cars on tumblr and i tweeted I
found both the guys on Twitter yeah I
was like who's doing the music for this
I want to do the music me me me me me me
and they're like yeah okay like I guess
like you can do it and then they they're
like yeah we've been making the game for
a week oh like hold back for a second
yeah yeah wait till we've actually got
some legal ways I'm making this music
like one of the first videos we put out
was this song this track with no
buildings in it yeah and I got a really
great response and we were like oh crap
like me we should
you know finish this like make it for
real yeah well there's something to be
said for like it used to be very much
like the old idiom of style over
substance we've seen so many great indie
titles over the past couple of years
like hotline miami springs to mind which
was like incredible style but also had
incredible substance as well so it's a
it's just it's real interesting that
like a team of three people can come
together and make something that sort of
functional interesting and then also you
know looks and sounds like something
that never played before that's the
beauty it's like you guys took ridge
racer and stuck like most disgusting
Instagram filter ATZ Elsa Graham filter
on it and then that was a video game we
took ridge racer and we made it good now
I'm just corrine I was after iteration
redress has been pretty pretty shitty
for the wall there so I wouldn't
wouldn't worry about it too much and
thank you so much for coming on I really
appreciate it a cute for the folks who
are interested in seeing more about
drift States and Isis and when is it
available to play for folks like those
who pre-order there's a free demo out
now on hio and then we're hoping to
release the full shebang-a-bang and
December excellence yes calendar year
yeah like if you enjoy thomas thomas
together for us thank you so much for
come on really appreciate it
you